I want to talk to you about big three
because I heard about this idea and I
thought that sounds like a great idea
not sure what its gonna look like and
then I started checking it out and it's
really fun yeah great idea it's great
why don't you explain and set up explain
the idea big three is professional
three-on-three basketball we all grew up
playing three on three and half court I
don't know if you played we are most of
us grew up playing three on three I love
to throw the old sphere in the piece in
my neighborhood we set up a peach pit
yeah we got a skit what a peach pit is
what's in the middle of a peach oh no we
couldn't afford that we had a peach pit
we had to put the ball through it was
hard anyway I'm an idiot so we got
former NBA players you know guys who who
no longer playing in the NBA but we
still know they got game and we put them
on we put a league together it's been
it's been a fun summer and we got our
championship game this Saturday on Fox
live so it's pretty cool to know what I
love when things are really first of all
it's great to see these players coming
back playing who's your oldest player
who's active would you say well our
oldest player is Charles Oakley
he got out there at 53 years old 53
anyway okay it's really great to see how
good some of them still are and they
still got game the other thing is you
have a four point there are stiffer --nt
areas of the court where you can shoot a
four point basket yeah yeah when I was
watching that's the one I was like I
want that to be in the NBA that's a
great idea yeah I think it's a great
idea you know I don't know if they'll
ever adapt it because of stats yeah you
know Kareem will probably be sitting
there saying man wait a minute you know
I got my tools and now you can shoot a
four so you know you never know but for
the big three is great you know it's a
great way if you shoot from that damn
far you should get extra points I got 13
I think stop the game and you should get
a cake
not a lot of ideas if you want me to get
in I got ideas I got ideas cube ain't
this segment almost over no go right -
yeah welcome to my world I got the rap
ten minutes ago but I got ideas we have
we have a little montage here just some
big three action just check it out it's
really fun let's take a look
[Applause]
here's four four
[Music]
power can win it right here Stevenson
[Applause]
Oh
what the King minutes is it's the most
fun I've had in my whole career man you
know putting a big three together
you